shady by the way you don't know this is
very hot for the Good Morning America
weather woman I don't even know who it
is JD who is it the one you're hot for
[Music]
unless I say that inside pay attention
to me we're on the air
pay attention to me I am doing something
while I'm talking to you you're playing
a game again I was getting like we
updates on my phone my watch thing and I
was looking at those for a second huh
what is Ronnie
hey what up he's got he's got that video
game going you could see it flashing in
the background now you just shut it off
you could see all the red and everything
weird I sound weird
you talk it through a harmonizer yeah
Ronnie say testing one two one two
testing one two one two you did but it's
kind of cool I didn't do anything I got
that no I wish I could do that you know
what we did you know we're trying to get
some of the key people on the show a
nice microphone set up in their house
and I said hey once you get where we
seem to talk to Ronnie a lot why not we
why don't we get them with a decent
microphone so this is the new microphone
I don't even know how Gary how is it
possible Ronnie could be on an effect
well I'm gonna explain this to you so we
sent Ronnie the equipment and we were
gonna work with him after the show today
to set it all up but Ronnie set it up
himself so like you know Stephanie set
it up the engineers have no idea how
this is happening I think they gave him
a joke Mike they got the victim they
forgot the mic Stan so I got the thing
sitting in a jar
eww you sound like lurch can you say you
you ran there you go Ronnie go fix your
microphone and I don't know what I think
this time you got something in the wrong
hole that's what's know that happens a
lot at night house